what exactly the AWS is and I'll be
telling you about
uh how does AWS works and what are the
topics that we need to cover up in the
AWS training
and this uh this session is going to
help you to understand
the AWS from the cloud computing
perspective
this way you can actually select your
career in the AWS platform those who are
from a non-technical background or those
who are from a different technology also
they can basically
understand the basic concepts of the AWS
from this session
so welcome on board and let's continue
before we begin let's take a trip down
memory lane
and let's look into
what exactly or what previous
technologies that we were working on
earlier
so in the year 2000 in the year 2003
2008 2010 and now there has been lot of
changes and obviously earlier we were
working on or we were focusing more on
the on-prem or the data center
Technologies where we used to have uh
the servers and the Computing devices at
our own premises
even if I talk about from the Enterprise
perspective also so a lot of companies
those who are from a non-technical
background also they used to have uh
their entire technical infrastructure at
their own premises
so sometime in the year 2000s
let's say a person
wants to implement a solution
and or a company wants to implement a
solution
the first thing they require is the
infrastructure they require the servers
so here you can see this person is
thinking about I want a few servers for
my new website let's say he has a plan
you want to set up a website or an
application for his business and what is
the main thing that is required the
servers
whether website or an application can be
hosted
the other person says sure it's not
going to be cheap though obviously if
you go to the market and try to buy or
procure a server
from the market it is going to cost a
lot depends on the Computing resources
depends on the capacity definitely
so it's not going to be cheap though
and the person in the year 2000 bought
some servers from the market and then he
is not happy he says that was quite an
expensive thing that I have purchased
and
he has taken all the risk and he hopes
that this is going to be worth it
a few months later
good news they love our website but
so the website has been deployed the
website has been created and the website
has been deployed on
the physical servers that the person has
procured from the market
but there is an issue
there is lot of traffic that is coming
on our website and we need to think
about scalability we need to increase
the server resources we need to increase
the capacity
so we require more servers a whole lot
more even more than what we procured and
definitely that is going to come with a
cost
so this person is thinking oh my wallet
is going to be empty in that case
right
now
let's try to understand the scenario in
the present day in the year 2022
if the same situation happened now
all that needs to be done is
we can
go to the cloud environment and we can
get our
get the servers or the virtual servers
running at no time
here you can see hey I'm going to need
more servers for my website
the represented says or the AWS
representative says oh that can be
arranged immediately
why not
so the person
in the year 2000 who procured the
servers earlier purchase the servers
from the market
got the servers from the AWS and the
scalability is no issue he got it at no
time and the good thing is that he has
to pay the amount only for the duration
the servers will be for the virtual
servers will be used so that's the
benefit of using the cloud platforms or
the cloud computing platforms like AWS
Google cloud and many more
now let's try to understand what we are
going to cover up in this agenda
we are going to understand what exactly
this AWS is how does it offers the
servers or the resources
we are going to understand about a brief
history of Amazon web services or AWS
what all type of services the AWS offers
and how does AWS makes our life more
easier
so let's understand what exactly the AWS
is
AWS is a secure cloud service platform
and it is named as Amazon web services
it has been owned by a company apparent
company called Amazon which is a very
popular name in the e-commerce platform
it offers the computing power
and along with that a lot many other
services related to different segments
like Computing storage databases and all
and with the help of or with the
offering of computing power
we can
get the servers or the virtual machines
from the AWS at any time
it offers us different type of database
services and the storage services
so on the AWS we can have not many type
of databases primarily related to SQL
databases or relational databases or the
nosql databases which are basically a
semi-structure kind of a databases like
mongodb and all
it gives us the storage capacity
and we can store lot many lot much lot
many information we can store on the
cloud on specifically on the AWS there
is one service called simple storage
service S3
that works just like a Google drive or a
Dropbox and here we can store our
documents our files
our video content audio content whatever
we can think of we can store it and
retain it for a longer duration of time
and the good thing is that the storage
is not
a concern it keeps on scaling and it
offers almost an unlimited kind of
storage
the content delivery
content delivery is very popular these
days there are so many content delivery
applications
the Ott platforms on which we watch our
favorite videos movies we hear
the audio of the songs all these are
related to the content delivery
and we can get that content stored on
the cloud on the AWS with the help of
the storage Services the database
services and we can get it delivered
with the help of the content delivery
services to various users across the
globe
the benefit of using the content
delivery of AWS is that it reduces the
latency of the content delivery and it
provides the uniform latency across the
globe for every user
so we can stream our favorite movies
audios songs anything with the same rate
if you are moving out to a different
locations as well
and the other main advantage of using
the AWS platform is we have to pay for
all these Services as and when we use
them
so we are going to pay as you go pricing
so let's say if I consume these services
for one hour duration or couple of hours
duration I'll I'll be paying to the AWS
for that duration usage only
and apart from that uh the AWS also
offers us some offers
subscription features where if you
subscribe for the services for one year
or three year duration we get some
discount rates on a per hour basis
so these are a couple of important
functionalities that the AWS offers that
makes it more popular in the cloud
computing environment
the application AWS crates are
basically reliable
scalable
flexible
now what does a reliable scalability and
the flexibility means
when we talk about the AWS in the back
end AWS uses a lot of infrastructure the
technological infrastructure and they
are up-to-dated infrastructure the top
most or you can say the most updated
servers they are using in their data
centers
and the good thing is their data centers
their availability zones their locations
where the entire infrastructure is
situated
that is spreaded across the globe in
various different continents
all of these locations are
interconnected using AWS private Network
the internal private Network and that
makes the AWS infrastructure more
reliable
we can plan the redundancy we can plan
the high availability of our
applications in case if any failure
happens we can quickly switch to
different location and there we can run
our servers and the applications
it gives us the scalability so as and
when we want to upgrade or we want to
increase the capacity of the resources
as we saw in the server example at the
beginning of the session we can scale
the resources as and when required so we
can scale up we can scale down as well
depends on
the requirement and the traffic as well
flexibility
we can
make the changes on the fly so if we
have the resources that are live that
are running and still we want to upgrade
them we want to make changes in our
applications we can do them even when
they are in a running State as well
now let's look into a brief history of
AWS
AWS was launched in the year 2002.
they launch its first Cloud product in
the year 2006.
they hold
the first customer event in the year
2012.
in the year 2015
they earned around 4.6 million dollar
Revenue
in the year 2015 and 2016 they released
a snowball and snow mobile kind of a
service
and these services are primarily used
to migrate large chunk of data
from one point to another point
these are portable kind of
Services where you can if you are having
a petabyte or
a terabyte kind of a data you can move
them
from one place to another so physically
the data and the storage devices are
moved
from the company's premises to the AWS
data centers and they are stored there
itself
it's across 10 billion dollar Revenue in
the year 2016.
and now it offers nearly 100 cloud
services even more than that into
various different business
functionalities so on the AWS we have
the services related to the cloud
or compute based functionalities we have
Services related to storages
databases
from the application perspective from
the automation perspective from machine
learning iot what not so lot many things
we can get from the AWS from the
technology point of view
what all services AWS offers
some of the popular Services AWS offer
or you must if you have worked
on the AWS
you must be knowing some of these
services like S3 the Amazon simple
storage service it is a very popular
service offered by the AWS and it acts
as a storage service
this can be used by anyone and it does
not require that much technical skills
to work on the S3
at an initial level as well
what is an S3 S3 is a service it is an
object storage service that can store
and retrieve data from anywhere at any
location
so for example let's say if you have
some content some documents like PDF
files or PowerPoints or audio or a video
content and you want to store them on
the cloud you can always upload them on
the S3
just like as I mentioned
you guys use Google Drive Dropbox
OneDrive to storing up the important
content similarly on the AWS you can use
Amazon S3 for storing up these files or
the objects
apart from that the Amazon S3 is not
only used for storing up the important
documents or the files or the objects
but you can have lot many features that
the S3 offers
it offers you the option of an automated
versioning of your
documents you can have a cross region
replications of your documents where you
can plan a redundancy of your documents
as well you can even host a simple
static website on the S3 as a simple
storage service and along with that
there are a lot many other features that
makes it more flexible
AWS data transfer AWS has number of data
transfer services like Kinesis it is a
data streaming service
import export snowball and Direct
Connect
with these data connect or data transfer
services we can quickly and securely
move large chunk of data from one point
to another point
we can even we can even do a live
streaming of the data and along with
that we can send that or ingest that
data into
different data warehouses or the
databases for the reporting and the
analytic purpose
Amazon ec2
Amazon ec2 provides secure and resizable
compute capacity
it is designed to make web scale
Cloud so Amazon ec2 stands for elastic
Cloud compute service
it is again one of the most popular and
the widely used service by the AWS
the Amazon through the Amazon ec2 we can
create lot many virtual machines virtual
servers based on different Computing
capacities
and we can host our applications
like we can build our websites we can
build mobile applications a lot many
applications can be hosted on the ec2
even we can plan to
customize the databases as well on the
ec2
so it's a quite a popular one highly
use service on the AWS and it works as
an infrastructure as a service kind of a
platform
then we have another popular service
often offered by the AWS and that is
called as an SNS which is a simple
notification service
and it enables
to send the messages which can be
delivered across a large number of
subscribers
systems like services and mobile as well
so SNS as a service which is basically
used to send out the notifications to
various different sources
and I can basically send out the
messages from the SNS
via or through
uh to the users over the email or
through the SMS as well along with that
I can send uh the messages
to three applications as well
so a lot many things we can do from the
SNS perspective
uh then we have the KMS which is a key
management system
and this is a service integrated into
most other AWS services and it helps us
to create and control uh the encryption
Keys used to protect the accounts and
the data
so with the availability of a KMS
you can encrypt the data
we can control the encryption and also
that makes uh
the logins on the AWS the data that you
store on the AWS
much more secure
then we have another service that is
called as Amazon Lambda
this is again a quite a popular service
which is uh which works as a serverless
architecture
so Amazon Lambda is a compute service
that executes code only when needed and
scale automatically
just give me a minute guys
yeah guys uh so coming back to the
service called AWS Lambda or the Amazon
Lambda
Lambda is a serverless architecture and
now when I say the serverless that means
we don't have to create
a server on the AWS or on the Lambda
just that we need to focus on developing
the code deploying it on the Lambda and
then the Lambda executes the code for us
in the back end definitely the servers
are created by the AWS but that is
something which we do not have to
and that's the reason we call Lambda as
a serverless architect
so what is the Lambda a Lambda is a
compute service that executes code only
when needed and scales automatically
since we do not have to plan the
creation of the servers
then we have a Route 53
the Route 53 is again a popular service
it's a DNS mapping service
and with the help of the Route 53 we can
map our external domains the DNS names
and point it to our websites or the
applications
so the Route 53 is a DNS web service and
it is designed to give developers and
businesses a reliable and cost effective
method to Route users to the internet
not many things we can do from the Route
53 perspective there are different type
of routing policies also that makes it
more feasible we can do a lot of
customizations also
now let's move to the next section and
that is how does AWS makes our life
easier why we should be using the AWS
platform we know that it offers a lot of
services but what exactly the Practical
use case of it
how does AWS makes life easier
here's the problem Unilever
Unilever is basically a company
I believe all of you must be knowing
about that
the Unilever wanted
or there was a need for faster time to
Market and a standardized environment as
well
how does or what approach the Unilever
followed here's how AWS makes the lives
easier AWS plus Unilever got increased
speeds of rollout and the deployment of
their applications
along with that they were also able to
get the cups and the disaster recoveries
guys the disaster recovery is a concept
where let's say if any kind of a natural
disaster or anything happens where that
particular location is not accessible we
plan a redundant location where at least
we can get our applications or the
current Or the critical resources
running
so we can very easily and efficiently
plan the backups and the disaster
recovery and that is one of the key
benefits of using the AWS Cloud platform
now let's look into another problem
statement
here's the problem Kellogg's faced
it was trying to add it was attempting
to improve trade spend and to move from
their usual infrastructure
how does that happen
AWS plus Kellogg's got greater
availability
cost saving
and when I say the greater availability
that means
the AWS was able to get the Kellogg's
application
available on all the different locations
in the form of a high availability
and with the available with the high
availability the Kellogg's was also able
to save lot of cost as they migrated uh
probably from the on-prem environment to
the AWS
so there was a cost saving they were
there was an improvement in the
architecture as well
so that was with respect to
what we understand from the AWS and how
we work on the AWS from the services
perspective
so guys let's take up some questions if
anyone is having any questions you can
let me know
please paste your questions guys